with the thirst and before your from
Calcutta which part I'm adopted I'm not
really mean you're starting to remember
Saru a beautiful boy very very proud of
yourself
a life I'd forgotten you okay I had
another family a mother her brother I
can still see their faces what happened
there's a word we got cuz I'm Lewbert
I have to find my way back home how long
were you on the train couple of days
couple of days it would take a lifetime
to search all the stations in India yes
idea what it's like how every day my
real brother screams my name is what
that I could keep this family together
I need your syrup what if you do find
home I'm not even there and you should
keep your jacket I don't have a choice
was she like beautiful
every night I imagine that I'm walking
those streets home and I know every
single step of the way
I'm whispering hurry
I'm here Maya Graham here crack I'm
gonna know I did the best I could
of course you did just saved everyone
people call you a hero I don't feel like
it
you know a good boy sellers